Try My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night,
all day.
I always find a way to get my shit
together and,
and dig myself out of a situations and
like,
and ultimately rise above beautiful as
long as you don't count on it right now
where I'm sick of getting in my own way
and like,
like UFC 200.
Let's talk about that.
I literally what happened.
I did everything that I could to be back
in the position to win that belt back.
I was getting ready to show this
triumphant amazing story of someone who
she's made it through a hit and run
situation.
It had almost had everything taken from
them and got it all back.
And then,
um,
and then,
I'm sorry,
I'm thinking about so many things at
once.
Might have been.
So let's just talk about what happened.
You,
you tested positive for some
estrogen inhibitors or blockers
yesterday and blockers that a lot of
people associate with people who take
steroids.
People take steroids and you want to
restart their system.
Or if you want a testosterone boost,
you take clomid or clomiphene and these
are,
these are standard drugs in the steroid
users world.
Yeah.
This is,
yeah.
All new for me.
Yeah.
Um,
basically what did you take?
So I took a,
I took an offbrand Cialis bill off
brand.
It was,
it wasn't actual Cialis,
but it was described to me as being a
cialis.
And so I thought it was a Cialis and I,
I just took it.
So why is it guy like you need.
Seattle's have a huge God,
Jo.
It's too big.
It's a good answer.
We don't have the resources to get it
normally.
Just,
yeah.
You know,
I um,
you were partying.
No,
it wasn't even necessarily party and
know I've taken like a melon hazmatt
before and for people who haven't taken
it,
you literally,
you know,
you go from being like that to just.
It puts the twist at the end of the
punch list at the end.
You know what I mean?
Is it like,
it,
it's,
it's a good time,
you know,
it's a good time to be a quote.
That's a good time.
Now.
Um,
what was this like?
One of them's gas station,
right?
Pills.
Yeah.
No,
I had an edit teammate basically tells
me,
hey,
uh,
he was talking about how his
girlfriend's a pharmacist and he,
he's capable of getting all this stuff
and,
and all that type of stuff.
And I was like,
wow,
I don't do drugs or anything like that.
And he's like,
you ever take a seattle?
Yeah.
So I was like,
yeah.
He's like,
I got to see Alice.
And I was like,
well,
you said you don't do drugs or anything
like that,
but you would done drugs.
Well,
yeah.
Yeah.
But no,
he was talking about all these
painkillers and all this different shit
than other things on top of that he has
because his girlfriend's a pharmacist
and he was,
she getting this off brand stuff from.
It's like,
I don't know,
people get a lot
of stuff from China.
I mean that's what happened with
Anderson.
Anderson got liquid cialis from China
and it was tainted.
Look,
this happens.
I know for a fact that,
I mean everyone knows for a fact that
happens.
The,
the supplement industry has a giant
issue with the people that mix the
stuff,
like if you have a VAT and you're mixing
up whatever,
creatine or something like that and
right before,
I mean,
if this is done in some country or some
place that doesn't have excellent
standards,
it's not scrupulous.
You could be scooping up steroids in the
batch before that and you just throw the
creatine in it and some of it gets
contaminated if they don't clean it.
Yeah.
That's pretty much a while.
I'll get to that.
But.
So you take this off brand Seattle guys,
like do you ever.
You ever do
flaggers and all that stuff?
And I'm like,
yeah,
I've,
you know,
I've had melanoma pills before and he's
like,
oh,
I guess yeah.
I was like,
oh,
this is great.
So I ended up taking one of the cialis
pills and um,
um,
and I thought everything was fine and
dandy.
I had no clue
what Ha,
you know,
that I,
that I was now having something else.
To me that was illegal.
I took her to the bill on June the 14th
of June,
16th.
Um,
you cited,
came over to my house 6:00 in the
morning.
Hey,
what's up guys?
That coffee going offer and everybody
water bottles.
Super Nice,
hospitable.
Come in,
laughing and joking with them.
I had no clue that that test was going
to be the test that derail my life.
And um,
you know,
right before UFC 200,
my manager now he calls me over to his
hotel room and he's like,
Hey,
I want to talk to you man,
like,
what's going on?
He's like,
Hey,
you're not going to be fighting.
Are you talking about?
He's like,
you know,
you didn't feel you didn't pass your
drug test and a,
the level of her and just and confusion
and I literally had an anxiety attack
and I had never had one of those before.
What does that feel like?
I felt like the whole room just came in
on me,
like the whole room came down on me and
I was just,
I couldn't breathe.
I remember opening up his hotel window
looking for a balcony so I could just
breathe and realize that I'm not
trapped.
Um,
there's a little window opened that much
so you don't trump hotel in vegas where
it was in Vegas.
Fucking freak and I'm breathing.
They don't want gamblers leaping through
the years
back in.
I'm breathing in through the thing,
calm myself down.
And um,
and I instantly started thinking about
the weight of the.
I had the weight of the world literally
on my back.
I knew that.
I knew that I wasn't going to be
fighting a few hours before everyone
else knew,
the public knew and I was just,
I could already start hearing
everything.
Even my uncle just been looking at me
like just their hearts were on the
floor.
Like I had done so much to get back to
fighting at UFC $200.
Like get my life in order,
getting the people around me in order to
my,
my health,
my mind,
you just being in order to beat DC.
And,
and like literally right now I've done
so much.
So much of the right things to be back
in a good position and right now now
people look at me as if I still don't
have my shit together,
but the only thing that I did was I took
a pill,
uh,
that I thought was gonna give me a boner
and it literally,
it's caused me a lot of heartache and a
lot of disappointment and a lot of just
threw me
here in any way,
shape or form.
When someone gives you this pill and you
don't know where it came from,
you don't know.
What did you think,
man?
I don't know what's in this.
No,
I didn't.
I didn't think of it because,
um,
I had been dealing with the athletic
commission.
I've been in the UFC for a long time and
I've taken a little gas station,
take pills before,
like,
you know,
and I've never felt the drug test ever.
Did you ever think that you might have
got lucky?
No,
I didn't think I got lucky.
I thought that you failed drug tests
when you're doing sketchy shit.
Right?
But didn't you think there might be some
sketchy shit?
And some Chinese,
no station Rhino,
Dick pill.
I,
um,
what you know about the rhinos.
My friend Ryan,
my friend Brian called it,
he was on the,
on the podcast.
He said,
know John Likes to party.
I bet he took one of them
pills.
Um,
no.
it's funny you called it.
Yeah.
Well he,
he was,
he was on.
I haven't,
I've taken them several times before.
And with the Nevada State Athletic
Commission,
I always pass my drug test and,
and I know that I would never do
anything to keep this sport,
have a lot of pride in my work ethic and
knowing that dude,
I've been skinny my whole career.
Whooping people's ass.
I'm not a knockout artist.
I wouldn't because I'm smart and you
know,
I work hard.
Um,
but with you with the Knob,
Nevada Athletic Commission,
I never had an issue.
And then I was suspended when you
started came,
so I was never really educated on how
serious you shot a really was like,
I um,
I came back into the game and there's
like,
oh,
hey,
we've got this new company name and
Usada instead of Nevada.
What were you suspended for when you saw
the king?
Oh,
you mean when they come into the sport?
I understand what you saying.
You know,
when they came into your house.
So when you started came into the sport.
I was looking because my head right.
And so I never had even met anyone who
worked for your side.
I'd never been sat down.
I know you started seminar,
what to do and what not to do and how
serious it is and what could have it if
you do this.
And only thing I knew is I had to report
where I was at.
Like if I go to La for the weekend,
I got a little sad to know that I'm in
La because like a drug spent anytime.
That's the only thing I really knew
about Usada.
I didn't know that.
Doing something that I had done several
times before I could ultimately lose me
a fight.
So I'm.
The only difference was I had taken like
little gas station pills and I've taken
by Agora before this was,
this teammate gave me something that was
Seattle is.
I thought the only thing that it would
do is make me bigger and stronger for
longer.
That's all I thought it was going to be
happening and then when I find out that
that I just failed the drug test.
Do you know that via Viagara is actually
illegal in the Olympics.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
You can't take that stuff.
The Viagra is a performance enhancer.
Vaso dilator,
I believe.
I believe that's how they describe it
and it actually has athletic performance
enhancing properties to it.
How does it,
how does it help you?
I don't know.
We'd have to look into that,
but I think it's similar in a lot of
ways to nitric oxide supplement.
Like a pro,
like a pre workout.
Get your.
Yeah.
It does something to open up your blood
cells and get you pumped.
I mean,
it does something not just to your Dick
but to all of your muscle.
Yeah.
I don't know if I would want it to be
pumped up during a fight.
I don't think it works that way.
I mean,
I don't.
I think it actually can possibly
potentially help endurance.
Well,
yeah,
I know,
but I know that athletes take it for
that reason.
That's why it's spanned from the
Olympics.
Yeah.
But,
um,
but yeah,
you know,
I understand that it wasn't your
intention.
It was not my intention and I had no,
I had no clue that I needed to report
this to your side up because I thought,
you know,
literally I was reporting everything
else.
What supplements,
what a pre workout,
what,
you know,
my amino acids,
protein powder,
like you saw that had all my stuff.
And what happens once you find out?
Did you,
how'd you narrow it down to this pill?
I literally,
I went through my supplements and I um,
handed it to.
I hired a private lab in the lawyer and
we started handing it,
given them everything that I took,
which isn't really a lot of stuff at all
know stuff that everyone should take.
Fish oil,
basic basic supplements,
protein,
protein powder,
fish oil,
um,
you know,
liver cleanse that like or whatever.
I'm just grapeseed extract,
that kind of stuff.
Very multivitamins for men,
Beijing very basic stuff.
And um,
and then,
and then get nutrition is like,
you know,
we,
we've scanned all of our stuff.
We know it's not from that gut nutrition
website though,
was fucking hilarious.
Gat Nutrition website at the moment we
found out about it that someone said,
John sponsored by Gat Nutrition.
So we've,
oh,
let's check that out.
Get nutrition is some fucking dude.
As soon as
they have a lot of great,
great products,
but if you want to get big and strong
and you can definitely go to them.
But as soon as we saw that,
we were like,
what in the holy fuck is he taking?
Oh No,
I mean,
but people saw you.
You've got gigantic electronically.
Completely,
completely,
completely natural.
That's what I have great pride in being
a natural athlete.
But um,
but uh,
so they got,
they got all the cat stuff,
test it and clear,
right?
Everything was clear.
Um,
this gets to have other things that you
don't regulate.
Absolutely.
But the things that they gave me,
they're super smart about and uh,
out in all the products I was thinking
with clear and um,
and so my managers,
I think outside of the box I did you
take anything that could have possibly
been.
And I was like,
I don't think so.
Then I was like,
well,
one of my teammates did give me this
pill and he's like,
I need those.
So where you got those pills tested and
sure enough,
they and their ingredients,
they listed about five products and
their ingredients.
And they actually are,
there's actually like seven products too
that weren't listed in the ingredients.
The two estrogen blockers were never in
their ingredients.
Um,
so,
um,
it was a tainted pill.
It would say what I'm saying.
Yes.
So,
um,
so the,
you,
you cited was able to tell,
okay,
this was totally inattention or there's
no engine,
no way in Hell I'm John would take these
estrogen blockers on purpose.
First of all,
it was very small traces,
so it wasn't like I was loaded up with
estrogen blockers and um,
why the fuck would they put estrogen
blockers and put them into digital?
We believe that,
uh,
the factory that created these,
these Dick Pills,
um,
were maybe manufacturing these pills in
a dirty laboratory,
whatever.
And because of this container just
tainted.
Yes,
because each pill that we,
that we had tested,
some of them had more estrogen blockers,
some had almost no estrogen blockers,
some head small traces.
Actually none of the pills were
consistent.
So it was obvious that.
And we,
we tested several different packages.
So it was obviously that,
that these pills were probably getting
made in the same machine and there was
just traces,
right?
Literally,
which is enough to show up in your
system.
When drug do.
We found some of these dick pills that
had none.
No estrogen blockers.
They're like,
damn,
why didn't I get that one?
Yeah,
exactly.
So I,
I took one that was just contaminated
enough and literally I got tested two
days later and it was in my system.
So it was,
it was obvious that it was complete
accident and even,
and even if I would have reported the
Deq pill to Usada,
they would have read the label and the
label would have never said that it was
estrogen blocker in there and I still
would have had a dirty.
Right.
Good attachments contaminated.
Where does that leave you?
How much time did they suspend you for?
I got suspended for,
for a year back from starting from back
in July.
So now I fight in July of 2000.
I'd love you shot up.
I love what they're doing.
I don't agree with things like that.
Because what you took does not enhance
your performance?
No,
it does.
It's especially in such a trace amount.
I feel like in certain circumstances,
like there's been several fighters like
Chad Mendez.
Um,
he has a,
I believe he has eczema.
He was taking an Eczema cream that had
some sort of a,
was it a hormone precursor or a hormone?
Peptide?
I believe some sort of a hormone
peptide.
I think that enhances the,
the use of this
preme.
I don't,
I don't know the full.
I'm
obviously not a doctor or a scientist,
but um,
there's something about suspending
someone for something like that.
That seems ridiculous.
Well,
in my situation they,
they,
the,
the evening you said his lawyer,
he showed,
he showed a little bit of remorse.
I could,
I could feel that he felt bad about what
was happening to me because I think he
could really,
even the arbitrators,
they could tell what had actually
happened,
but their problem was they said John was
just negligent.
Like you didn't,
you should have reported this pill,
but it seems to me that's silly.
But even if I were to report it the
pill,
they would've read the ingredients and
they would've never saw that there was a
trace of,
of something that wasn't advertised.
So why suspend someone for something
like,
because they,
they.
Because they said it was zero tolerance
policy.
It was just like I was the first fighter
to ever take them to into arbitration
and and they were more upset that I
didn't let them know that I took the
pill.
Then what actually happened was like the
rule is you tell us what you take and we
can point you in a different direction,
but I never told him what I took.
My whole argument was if I told you what
I took,
it still was never on the label.
Yeah,
so unless you guys were going to spend
all the money to take it to a private
lab or take it to a laboratory to test
this individual pill,
you get what I'm saying?
I still don't run into the same
situation.
I think it's great to protect people
from people that are cheating.
I don't think it's great to punish
someone for taking something that has a
trace amount of something that does them
absolutely no benefit whatsoever and
clearly.
And was it supposed to be in that bill
and wasn't supposed to be in that pill
and clearly wasn't being taken to
enhance athletic performance.
Right.
That seems silly.
It seems like a mess.
It seems like a mass that.
I mean,
I,
I understand there zero tolerance
policy.
I don't agree with it.
In this war of the Chad Mendez
situation,
you know,
there's,
there's weird ones like Yoel Romero.
He tested positive for something.
They found out that it was a in one of
the protein powders or something.
He was taken.
It wasn't supposed to be in there,
wasn't listed that way and they gave him
an abbreviated sentence.
You should have.
No,
no,
no part of it whatsoever.
But my whole thing is I'm so grateful.
I'm still optimistic,
man.
I'm always looking for light in every
situation
and I think that's the way I deal with
things.
I just am always trying.
I always believe there's going to be
good.
At the end of the day,
that's just how I am.
I'm just so grateful where most people
would be so upset with themselves and
all this type of stuff.
I'm really not.
I'm upset about the fans that are let
down who flew out to UFC 200 and things
like that,
but as far as the whole situation,
I'm just glad that that my,
my name will no longer be associated
with steroids.
Right.
Rather be vulnerable boy or whatever you
want to call me,
you know,
whatever you want to call me,
but steroids that that was really.
That was really bothering me,
so I'm just glad that it's out.
What actually happened.